a disc is initially rotating clockwise
around a fixed axis with angular speed
omega naught
at time t equals 0
the two forces of f sub 1 is equal to 20
newtons and f sub 2 is equal to 10
newtons are exerted on the disk as shown
in the figure below so these are the
magnitudes but here they show the
magnitude and the direction and they say
which graph could show the angular
velocity of the disk over time so before
i even show you the options let's see if
we can just sketch it ourselves so pause
this video and see if you can sketch the
angular velocity of the disk over time
all right so
in our vertical axis here
let's put our angular velocity
and then in our horizontal axis here we
want to see how that changes over time
so what is our initial angular velocity
well they tell us that our angular speed
is omega naught and the direction is in
the clockwise direction they sit right
over there and the typical convention is
that clockwise
clockwise is negative and
counterclockwise would be positive so
we're starting at a negative negative
angular velocity so we're starting at a
negative angular velocity let's see
right right over there and it actually
would be
negative omega naught i'll just write
negative omega naught remember omega
naught is the speed the angular speed so
it's the magnitude of the angular
velocity but since we're going clockwise
it would be negative so we're going to
start
right there
and now let's see what the net torque is
f1 we're assuming goes straight down and
it's perpendicular to the radius
let's call that r that length r and f2
is straight down it's perpendicular to
the radius but f1 is providing a torque
in the counterclockwise direction while
f2 is providing
a torque in the clockwise direction and
the way it's depicted f1 is larger and
they're both are away from the center of
rotation so your net torque is going to
be
counterclockwise it's going to be
against the direction or the starting
direction of rotation and so if your net
torque is counterclockwise so we could
say our net torque is going to be
positive
and if our net torque is positive that
means that our angular acceleration is
going to be
positive and our angular acceleration is
just the rate of change of our angular
velocity and this is going to be
constant assuming that these forces are
constant and so you're going to see this
we're going to be rotating clockwise at
a slower and slower rate until all of a
sudden the wheel switches directions and
then or the disc which is directions and
then all of a sudden we are rotating
counterclockwise so it would look
something like that so let's see which
of these choices fit
so if we look at all of them this looks
almost exactly like we drew but let's
just review what these other ones are
saying
this one is implying here that you're
starting off going clockwise but then
you're accelerating in the clockwise
direction and that wasn't the direction
that the net torque was being applied in
so we ruled that out
this assumes that you're starting in the
counterclockwise direction which we know
is not the case
this assumes that you're starting in the
counterclockwise direction and then you
are and then you are accelerating in the
clockwise direction and you would have
picked this if you got your convention
mixed up between counterclockwise and
clockwise and which one is positive or
negative but we can rule that one out
and the choice is a